so
good morning everyone welcome back to
gamesbot live i'm richie and today we
are going to be playing a little call of
duty warzone to check out the vanguard
event so thanks for tuning in
be sure to like the video if you're
excited because we are gonna play we're
gonna play a little early first uh it's
a good idea for us
uh and by us i mean aaron sampson i'm
joined here by aaron samson
um i think we're gonna fight a train
today or something do you think we're
gonna fight a train today yep that is
what's
rumored to be going on so
let me swap over here no train just yet
the event starts at
uh in like you know roughly an hour but
we want to be we want to be in the lobby
we want to have a game going so we have
a better chance to um
uh get our spot in this virtual line if
you will
what's up chad how's it going thank you
all for watching we've got uh we're live
streaming on
twitch on youtube
on two youtube channels we have our
gamespot trailers channel so hi to
everyone who is watching from everywhere
here's me and aaron there we go booted
up walking infinitely um
looks like rebirth resurgence quads is
still going on same with trio so
uh let's play some of these they got
double xp going
see if we get some randos in here
and just play until the event actually
starts how's everyone doing
in the chat with something
yeah
honestly richie and i are very proud
middle of the road call of duty players
we want to represent you by being
average
absolutely
i'm really curious what people feel
about the world war ii setting though
like uh richie and i actually went to a
world war ii
event already we can't really talk about
that until or we're putting some videos
after this stream out about that
um
but man like we're big on the modern
warfare crowd
and like this game turned hard away from
modern warfare during cold war
it did really curious like cold war
really absorbed this um this game and
we've been over that so many times and
and how much we love modern warfare so a
little hard to see but at its core
especially due to the game engine this
game is
sort of like a shadow of what it once
once was at least but probably because
all the guns the gunmeta changed
entirely but erin and i have been over
that a lot we are
as he said middle of the road
warfare fan so don't expect some high
kill
gameplay middle of the road
that was on purpose by the way
all right vanguard is basically world
war ii but germany and japan somehow
starting to win the war completely huh
where's actually from
yeah look in the chat right now
i've not played uh rebirth island in a
while i i'm so back and forth with it
like when i there you can have a lot of
good games on this map because it's so
small um
but something about it like i don't know
what it is something about it doesn't
make me want to click into it like
instead of for dance i don't know i also
haven't been playing a lot of warzone in
general lately i had a had a dust off
you know
uh uh
see where my skills were yesterday today
but i'm ready you know i played warzone
so much at launch
oh here we go
sorry that
that's news good question
what i understand it's pretty normal
pretty fair
um
the the two new guns that were added
last week the m2 and the tec-9 are kind
of breaking things a little bit
um
from what i heard like a little bit not
as bad as you know
soy coffee week or uh
other guns we've had in the past
holy crap hey you're the squad leader
actually we should just pick something
there we go
let's go all right we're landing over
here
you guys are gonna have to bear with us
because like i said we're like big
modern warfare players we kind of like
went away from this update
cold war took over not the cold wars
those were just like classic call of
duty
we were looking more for the modern
warfare angle
yes oh i landed in another spot i'm far
away from you guys
come back i'm coming i'm coming i'm
loading up on guns ah box over here yeah
it's nice to play with like i feel like
aaron uh we every time we try to play
together uh i think i've only played
with you in spirit and no voice
there you are
hey yeah so we'll talk about
that
oh
aaron aaron you cut out a little bit
there
oh no i cursed it as soon as i said i i
play with aaron and spirit only oh
there's a badger over there
no
dude this guy needs to die okay
that was not a
team
we're bad teammates aaron we got to find
our friends
oh no oh wait i thought aaron was being
shot
freaking out a little too much
that was
incredibly lucky
oh crap
hold on aaron
they go
oh yourself
where'd that guy go
all right i'm not gonna peek my head out
there anymore let me try to go around
here
and um
actually armor up while i'm here
we're off to a really jumpy start i'm
glad we haven't died yet though i
probably just jinxed us but thanks for
tuning in chat uh for anyone just tuning
in we are we will be playing the event
once it starts at 10 30. we just wanted
to get into a lobby first
so that we have a better chance of um
actually
you know
getting in
all right wow
this is pretty intense this whole start
here
plates and if you need plays i'll see
you right here
well
this one right here
mark from gear let me see here
long button wow look at that it should
have sprayed for no reason
guys feel free in the chat to call me a
bot um it's been a little bit i've been
playing so much zombies uh that i forgot
the button layout of all this
look at that there's me there we go
aaron here take a plate or two if you
need them
i need a plate up and then i think we're
back in this all right
my camera's lagging you're right all
right let me swap over to thank you for
pointing that out i have
fortunately i think i've got two cameras
uh one two three boom there we go this
one should be better that little
logitech camera i have stinks
now you're the one you're looking at uh
is this sony one that we're giving it's
very nice maybe a little too hd this
ugly mug
but fortunately it's a small screen all
right here footsteps aaron be careful
down here
freaking out i'm just hiding in a prison
cell
okay those were aaron's footsteps
i can't believe oh no aaron this stinks
i lost i lost your voice bro
where are our friends
we're healing
oh they're they're okay we're playing
resurgence so they'll be back here in a
second
[Music]
every time i play this part of the map i
just think of uh call not called the
dead uh mob of the dead because this is
a it's alcatraz it's the same map
you got me
you got me bro
mr cowboy over here
multicam though
pro streamer
thanks thanks persia in the chat um
i just was lucky enough to have a camera
before
gamespot gave me one so that's cool
what time is the reveal hey non not
forgotten in the chat um
the reveal the the event starts at 10
30. so we gotta do the event once it
starts and then um they'll probably
reveal whatever is going on after that
so you know we wanted to start the
stream early
because last time we started like right
at 10 30 and
we didn't really have a good shot
we had to wait
so we just want to be in a lobby
before
uh the actual event starts so we have
better luck
uh getting into a
you know
a game of the event the the
better time getting into the event this
guy again
this cowboy dude just execute me man rub
it in
i do love deadshot
not too mad
cowboy dude
good thing there's resurgence because uh
the game's the gameplay speaks for
itself
what's up with cheat zone oh my god this
game is
um i'm really glad i'm playing on
playstation but aaron is currently on
xbox and he can't turn cross play out
that's so sad
but it's still you know a serious
serious problem right now
oh crap
don't you dare wait where the hell oh
oh i killed a phase guy i'm about to die
okay i know just because he's wearing
that he's not actually phased but
it felt good i got another kill
running away running for my life
okay
a little second to breathe here
okay
man the pressure's really off when it
comes to uh
playing resurgence instead of regular
battle royale
because uh all my friends
you guys played with the tec-9 or the m2
much yet um they're both apparently both
pretty broken this you can you can
convert this gun into a full auto or
three-round burst but it starts up as a
semi-auto like what
oh my god that's the full auto that is
logo
all right let's let me find my friends
instead of just
being alone
what steps
yeah my friends are all dying over there
i should go
here's someone
oh they're above me damn it
i'm i'm not running on purpose so they
don't hear me it's that easily enemy
soldier ain't coming
i want to sneak up on them
oh that's aaron
you gotta
i wonder if aaron survived no it doesn't
look like he did damn
not bad uh for me for me five kills up
there on the top right not bad
this because this gives me a good
opportunity to read the chat too how's
it going you guys
that's another world war two game yeah
talk about that uh vanguard is
officially
was officially teased as a world war ii
game
and uh how do you guys all feel about
that
10 30 a little closer to 10 30.
uh i want aaron at my party okay
no they didn't reveal it yet it is
currently 9 51 where i'm sitting and the
event starts at 10 30. uh we just wanted
to play a little early to get into a
into a lobby because last time it took
us a while to get into a lobby
just booting from the game um
so we're going to be we want to be in
the servers when this event starts but
check it out up top 38 minutes left
let's do some more um no not mini let's
go back to re
rebirth resurgence
yeah as soon as the event starts um
at 10 30 we want to jump right in and
see what's up with this uh this train
apparently
all right
king scotto in the chat says i love
world war ii cool this year is for you
my man
muhammad also says i love world war ii
cool
yep that's correct
abby power says 1 30 eastern standard
time that's when it'll happen for y'all
i'm here from uh
here on the west coast myself
um
i'm reading more chat some more mixed
opinions about world war ii
um
yeah world at war 2 would be cool i
guess because i love roll that war from
uh you know
2008 so much but
they wouldn't they wouldn't do that
that's an important game though that's
where zombies started man
let me know something in the chat you
guys um
when modern warfare 2019 first came out
i had motion blur on all the time and it
didn't bug me
until i got to uh live streaming this
one time i was live streaming it and or
anytime i captured footage from modern
warfare and it had
you know my motion blur on i turned it
off
but everyone's like what are you doing
like are you a bot like turn that off
it's like okay let me know what you guys
think because i was like it so doesn't
bother me but i don't know i also don't
play you know
uh
professionally i guess or uh
at a very high skill level so does that
does motion bur motion blur bother you
guys
because i'm very interested uh
at how
how hostile the responses were for
turning on motion
anyway
it's off now and i don't really don't
all right that's enough
for real
here we go
marcus berlin says motion blur off
tell me why does it really help
like turning from left to right does it
blur your camera enough to where you uh
you know have trouble seeing someone
someone in chad says i love motion blur
i just i'm like i don't care about it
but people are really defensive on their
stance and that's okay you're passionate
about something but
if you don't
oh shoot this map is so small
jumping on green let's go let's go let's
go
right i'm going
hey who turned my auto shoot deployed
back on
how long has it been
another ak another day another aka all
right
what was that
we kicked open the door
shots are being fired
around
relax homeboy
like this and this and this and close
this
in the barn
this guy's name i'm not gonna read that
i think i saw a bad guy
parachute
you're mine
no time for that
where are the damn stairs
actually should i swap out i don't want
this dumb gun
okay actually that gun wasn't that bad
whoa render foe please don't jump over
me
uh but yeah as you can see i've turned
motion blur off and that's that's the
end of that let's take it
i hope it happens
whoa someone's freaking out with their
pings
[Music]
okay how about i drop off my money too
so someone else oh wait hold on yeah
take this uh my sack just take my money
and let's get us get us to get us a uh
loadout please or something
no we're not there yet we're not we
don't have enough for a letter but
we'll soon
more money here more money here
oh what's this one oh okay i remember
that one that one's okay in fact you
know what i have two aks let me just
swap one of them for this
how are we doing you guys
i haven't checked on chat in a second
i'm in the zone you know what i'm saying
i mean aaron are in the zone i am
playing with aaron sampson uh his mic
went out i don't hear him anymore but he
is he is right here he is don't leave
him bro
[Music]
we close his doors please
someone
someone is going off up there on the
roof so you probably see somebody let's
yeah let's see what he see what he sees
at okay
here we go it's just about to i was just
wondering about our loadout drop
there we go
well if you guys want to see the new
em-2 gun or at least
the newer weapons
there we go
i also have the the tec-9 and the the
cx-9 aka the scorpion i unlocked
all those things
grinding the only one i don't have yet
is um
oh what don't i have um oh and i have
the marshall the new shotguns the little
you know sawed-off shotguns
this dude is firing off he sees somebody
over there he already killed that guy
i already have one of those drums i've
never used these drones
cxd
all right all my friends i'm going to
stay with my friends on this
oh someone's using the authentic i hear
it i hear it
you know what let me go back to that
window um
i have to go up
um
had a good good view out there
ooh
spicy i'd like to keep my head out i
heard that let me see what's going on
over here
aka this is not the ak the em-2 here
is good it hits hard but it's got some
long range
holy crap i've got some long-range um
recoil
but i haven't used it in war zone yet
i've only used it in like zombies and um
multiplayer cold war multiplayer
obviously
we are posted up here and this is this
is our building we we run this right now
i'm probably going to get oh
yeah
we'll probably get uh i was about to say
i'll probably get sniped from hanging
out up here too much but
oh
[Music]
hey close the door on myself
oh no oh crazy on the roof he's on the
roof
chilling chilling using my using my
equipment first
where's he okay let me revive him
all right oh he got sniped i believe
okay
i'm taking that
i love the fennec i've loved the fennec
from the beginning
you know what i don't love is the iso
that's awesome
[ __ ]
you see what i'm talking about
i would have lost
i should
that's cool i haven't seen how it works
yet
okay
not doing too bad
too bad this is not aggressive
this this gameplay
apology war zone
um
but it's a different map it's not the
old verdance you're used to this
turn around for a while it's a rebirth
map rebirth island
okay our friends are ditching air we
should we should leave
there is also a bounty on you aaron and
here i am slamming doors like a damn
fool
wait friends wait
we've moved on
i haven't streamed in a while you guys
it's
i don't know how you guys do it uh i can
barely keep two thoughts on my head let
alone
survive
help
please don't revive yourself i need to
breathe
my friends are dying
get away from me
i need my fennec right now
hold me hold me tightly fennec
goodies
yo
oh i was trying to i was trying to um
trying to plate up my armor but i got
this cool perk as you can see you know
that new one that came out um so i don't
need it
i'm already fully loaded on armor great
all right
whoa
you know
you saw how i hesitated there i thought
that wasn't a bad guy because my
friend's name tag was over his head so
i'm just getting lucky with all my kills
thank you guys for uh tuning in and
hopefully being
[Music]
why am i sweet
oh the smoke i mean the gas i mean i'm
screwed
oh man my friends came out of nowhere at
the perfect time thank goodness
oh i'm gonna go down i guess
let's uh let's reconvene down here boys
oh my god chad how are we doing
actually i'm in a safe spot
i
here
oh
some dude is sniping right above me
needs to stop
this is my friend okay
oh god i'm freaking out you guys
i'm freaking out because we've made it
this far
this is where i panic bad guy
never mind it's getting shot out of the
air
uh for those of you just tuning in the
event starts at 10 30 so in another half
hour um but we wanted to play
we wanted to be in the servers
uh because last time we weren't in the
servers we started right at 10 30 and we
had to wait for a long time so we're
just playing a little warm-up a few
warm-up rounds and then we are going to
do the event when it starts
oh
edgy's on the roof
our friends have definitely moved on i'm
here with my sack um
and we're the only ones left
here we go he's up there he's gonna have
to jump down
come on friends
you
i see this as a good thing
let's see who wins
i don't want to see you
all right it happened anyway someone won
but we left
oh no you guys um another half hour the
event starts at 10 30. and right now
here on the west coast it is
10 o'clock
thanks persia nice try third wasn't bad
i was freaking out i can barely do two
things at once but i appreciate that
uh let's do it again we got you know we
got we got some time we got actually um
20 minutes here so let's keep going 24
minutes yeah
ah aaron it's mike yeah that sucks we
had just started talking we were just
chatting it up
then eric aaron's mic just died on
discord
gg uh thank you who's that starcraft
thank you
that em-2 wasn't bad in um
in war zone i haven't used it in war
zone yet
if you buy the battle pass with 20 tier
skips
from where you are hold on only read
your question properly
uh if you buy there's a premium bundle
of premium battle pass you can buy that
skips like yeah something like that like
15 20 tiers i forget
but you know it costs more cod points
vanguard uh no tanner hey thanks for
joining um
the the
call of duty
vanguard event is today
uh and it's it's it's an event within
warzone and the event starts at 10 30.
right now we're playing a little early
because we just want to be in the
servers
um last time we were not in the servers
and we didn't get it into a game for
like 15 minutes and it sucked so we're
just playing until 10 30 and then we'll
do the event right away
hopefully we can get in with no problems
but yeah vanguard confirmed it's a world
war ii game and they're gonna reveal it
um
with an event in war zone today that's
what's going on
boom
atar says battlefield 5 is amazing here
we go we got some battlefield fans are
you ready for the new battlefield atar
am i saying your name right uh i am i've
never played a battlefield game and i'm
really excited
uh they're all a lot of them are free on
xbox game pass and i'm like no
look we got a clown on our team
although i look like a clown with my
mask on
we got a clown
rambo what kind of this is call of duty
in 2021
oh my god i'm just gonna jump i don't
know what i'm doing
okay yep
i'm trying to clean i confirm
watch out for that seagull
i don't want this sniper i like but it
takes way too much time
to kick back the next bolt
so i don't want to use that
and they give me another sniper gray
they're punishing
who an assault rifle
i think it was already taking rats
upstairs it's the em-2 also that's my
good luck weapon i'll go i'll get that
up here how the hell where are the
stairs in this place
oh my god i feel like such i don't play
rebirth very much
i mean we'll call that my excuse but um
here we go i also don't want to just
sound like a loser bot
yay
yeah
thanks aaron
teamwork makes the dream work hopefully
this this uh this helps okay let's we
have let's go meet up with our friends
looks like they are up north
uh another area we're playing with wait
see the clown or is he
um i like rebirth currently because they
have a resurgence and me and aaron we
like to die and we like to come back
we opened with that it was pretty great
when the stream started we were like you
know
you guys know us at all we know uh we
are we are
not you know we don't get those we don't
go the uh those oh shoot
we don't get those high kill streaks i
have the sniper still this is funny look
i'm letting this guy live
you see that's the kind of skill you're
dealing with here a lot of luck on our
half
um
we did it we lived
i got lucky so many every kill almost on
stream today has just been luck
except when i have the fennec in my
hands that's when it's like
untouchable i love the fennec
from the very first call of duty i
played i've always been like a spray and
prey dude like it's funny i've played
every call of duty uh multiplayer since
cod 4 and i would say my skill has
it hasn't gotten worse but it has gone
up like
this much
like overall and i play them to [ __ ]
like look at i'm prestige like
god
i forget what prestige i am currently i
play so much but it's weird that my
skill doesn't get
better i don't know i i also don't
stream like professionally than that um
these guns stink so many snipers
oh here we go
but i mean i just like to have fun with
this
uh
you can relate let me know in the chat
my friends i gotta get out of the i
gotta get out of the ring of smoke here
i already did that okay
all right chad is saying 18 minutes left
baby
yeah are you guys gonna play i mean it's
nice that you're here watching the
stream with us
but are you gonna try to get into the
servers as well and do the
vanguard review
should probably try to get in now but
you know keep an eye on the stream
we enjoy your support in your viewership
oh yeah take my money rambo
i don't want to buy that box i'm always
too scared to buy loadouts because i'm
always the one that gets sniped
out
one thing i will give warzone
is that just by holding a gun you get xp
for it i haven't i've killed one guy and
i got
xp for doing nothing just now
thanks rambo
can i call you john
okay i got a better em too this one's
kitted out better and i'll take the ak
back
you guys played with the cx-9 yet um the
scorpion i just unlocked it yesterday
it's really good
i'm very happy with it it's like
everything i wanted it isn't like it's a
fast fire rate kind of you know shitty
recoil but fun um so fun it made me like
fall in love with modern warfare all
over again i love modern warfare
more than i do cold war
so it was nice to grind in modern
warfare and
unlock that gun like old times
i love how chill you are oh thank you
thank you for and thanks for being here
thanks for watching me and aaron are
gonna play
this event when it starts at 10 30. but
for now we're just playing a little um
another one
he almost he almost reads all the way
oh
okay
great
let's uh raise this fool because satchel
good stuff good stuff
can't wait for a skill-based matchmaking
yeah i'm sorry sorry to be that guy to
say it'll probably never go away i hope
um
it's a little more relaxed in vanguard
that's all we can ask for is relaxed
skill based master making otherwise it's
a mess
like for better or worse but
complicated issue
aaron you need the satchel go for it man
okay
uh aaron was on mike but his mic
died on discord i can't hear him but he
is here he is a uh senior video producer
from gamespot.com playing with me right
now
[Applause]
where's the homie there he is right
there
oh maybe i should get out of the open
what the hell am i doing
live here
whoa someone's up there as well
this thing is okay the em2 not gonna lie
jumpy and uh i am not a pc god with my
recoil so i will
so i will relax
will relax with long distance
engagements
at least i'll tell you in fact let's use
it right now are they
wait i heard someone dropping into the
parachute
sorry stitch
wait oh no they shot the other air no
two of them there's another one
oh please don't
something longer
oh
aaron okay
guys
for now
top seven
all right anyone need gas mask
i need actually you need a satchel y'all
can have that
please don't threaten me like that
okay we gotta move the gas is coming in
i'm gonna keep it low and keep it down
here
there's a bunch of air strikes going off
right now as we speak
oh god please don't spam the chat guys i
don't know what that is
someone's just typing s
okay someone's above me see this is why
i kept it low keep it low low-key below
i like this uh ots gun i haven't used it
much outside of zombies
easy to know if i haven't made it very
clear i play a lot of zombies almost
exclusively this is a better ots yes
who are you fighting
i use my deadly silence i swear there
were people around here
there are
three of them i don't know if i should
be coming up here
really knowing well aaron's with me
there he is there's one guy
careful
trying to guess us
they're waiting up there
okay thanks to the airstrike that for
the assist there
actually the airstrike did all the work
and we finished them off
[Applause]
he's down oh no
we've got cali sticks i'm doomed
careful aaron there's someone out there
probably rezzing as we speak
[Laughter]
just call me fenic you guys that's
that's my name richie fennick the fox
i learned that that's what that is fanuc
is just is a type of fox so that's that
was cool
although it is just the gun itself is
the vector i think really call into your
life i don't remember
they'll have to rename guns in this game
who's shooting up here
oh my god is that a bad guy rezzing
right before my very ears
goodness gracious great balls
i'm almost there
aaron that claymore dude that claymore
saved my life
at the risk at the loss of yours
oh my god
i do not use tacticals as much as i
should as much as i should that was
great that was clutch let's get the hell
out of here
okay we are losing space quickly
all right i'll go i'll take i'll take
point watch out
moving again oh my god this music i have
i keep the music on
so that i can hear
audio levels on the stream
and uh right now it's it's
freaking me out oh i'm such an idiot
there we go there we go there we go nope
still got my mask still got my mask
oh my goodness
this
mask at that you see those bot shots
guys
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
i'm toast you guys
all right all right sorry sorry
yay
i did it
oh man
oh man
oh it's so good to do on stream i
oh here it is
[Music]
there she is
[Music]
oh my god my heart is racing y'all
that was good
first of those godlike oh my god you
guys are you guys are too kind yay
thanks ben good game thank you guys it's
always it's always nice to get a dub on
stream of course that was great oh i
can't stop smiling way to go yeah
we did it all right guys stream's over
just kidding
um
actually we have seven minutes until the
event starts
um
thanks guys oh love it love the
positivity i'm
thriving that was great all right i need
another i need to stay hydrated
i would say that's uncommon so i
appreciate you guys being here
uh if that was dope you got to drop a
like on this video please do it for me
let him know that that was dope
what am i doing i can't even think that
was fun
okay well we have seven minutes maybe we
can play um
i don't know we
still some time here
six minutes you know what i might just
wait it out and chat with you guys what
do you guys think either that or a small
match of like rebirth uh trios which
where we don't
respond in um
i'm unsure what to do i think i'm gonna
make the call right here to just
hang out for another five minutes and
chat with you guys um
and if we want if you want we can talk
about
vanguard that's coming up for sure
that's what this whole event is about in
five minutes
there will be a warzone event where they
introduce vanguard and
um
not much else is known about it but
we're going to get into it soon aaron
and i went to a
a a uh event where we talked all about
vanguard there's we can't say much yet
but later today we will have a video up
all about what we saw
ah thanks you guys uh chat is still
going off thank you guys so much i'm
watching the chat on youtube uh but if
you're watching somewhere else thank you
so much i haven't i don't have the other
windows open i think we're on twitch and
the other youtube page so thank you
thank you guys
um
yeah in
five minutes here the event will start
aaron and i are
infinitely walking here in a lobby ready
to go uh
last time we tried to
start
the live stream right at 10 o'clock and
um it didn't you know we we had to wait
for a
a lobby we had to wait for the server it
was crashed hard so we wanted to start
early today and um
make sure we got in just in time
thomas butler gang gang war zone win
hey devonta hey
which was he says wish it was modern
warfare 2. yeah let me know i mean there
are so many call of duty's that's
something we can talk about in chat let
me know
what is your favorite call of duty i
mean that can mean
and that can mean for multiplayer only
or um
you know it can mean for the campaign
let me know let me know and why
look at all these bundles dude
i don't like see on the top of the
screen the little green dots i hate
those so i always try to clear them out
if i can but i swear they make it
impossible in warzone
like look at this this little green dot
above the word battle pass i just want
it gone
and it doesn't go away
stop
maybe in the meantime we can build the
new uh em2
excuse me one sec
get some water
someone says cod mobile oh oh the
results are coming in forget the forget
the loadout let me read what you guys
are saying
okay let me actually oh my god
thanks for the the quick response you
guys jumped on that okay imran says
black ops three
um
uh christian says finest hour nice pick
that one's fun i love finest hour
infinite warfare man
we got results from all over the map
uh red panda says modern warfare 2019
that's a great choice
uh a few people back to back are like
cod two um is the goat all right
cod 2 i wish i got to play more
multiplayer um i was not playing
like online games at that point in my
life i didn't have an xbox yet but
the campaign for
pod 2 regular call of duty 2 is good uh
i think it was treyarch's first
um
first
develop game in the call of duty series
okay now i'm scrolling now i'm trying to
keep up with the chat here we go thanks
guys call of duty 4 for the win of
course i love nothing but love for cod
4. that's the one that's where i started
finest hour on ps2 hell yeah
black ops 4 okay
you know at first i was like when black
ops 4 was announced i was like oh man
like there's no
there's no campaign and then when i got
to playing it i was like that doesn't
need to be a campaign i don't think
maybe there doesn't need to be a
campaign every year especially because
um
you know remember how weird black ops
3's story was like it was cool but it
was weird and very unrelated to
uh what they established it was way too
into the future um
you know but on its own like if it
didn't say oh
whoa
here we go
excellent that's what you'd love to see
i am here two minutes away
downloading the latest update okay
okay uh i'm okay good me and aaron are
back too great look at that one more
minute you guys whoo
yes the battle of verdansk that's what
they're officially calling it yeah there
it is good stuff
um
max in the chat is asking uh is there a
world war ii trailer uh
hopefully there will be after this event
the event starts at 10 30.
we do the damn thing and hopefully the
event
ends with like a trailer for vanguard
that's what i'm hoping for it's kind of
what they what they generally do so
we're hoping
you guys see the the like the ads for
the battle of verdansk on twitter they
have all this cool like old-school
like artwork it kind of reminds me of
like those old like i don't even know
what to call like those propaganda
e-posters that are really like bold like
we need you um they were all over
twitter yesterday official stuff too
so it looked really cool
squad filled required we're gonna need
hmm
that's strange
um
you're gonna need
dudes hopefully it auto fills i mean i
don't need to oh here we go
no okay good squad fill required that's
fine we're gonna need a team of four it
looks like whether or not um we want it
i'm here with aaron aaron sampson who
was
donating me bro he's right here
um
and i can't think of anything else to
say i mean we're ready to jump into
the event here i'm going to start as
soon as it does
that oliver desk all right we're gonna
get two randoms
we're gonna see this out
if we get like a cool cut scene guys i'm
gonna cut away to like just
to just that so you guys can view
check it out for yourself i hope they
have a trailer um
i hope so
here we go it's loading
i'm glad we're at this point last time
we were just stuck outside looking in
and we could not play we couldn't even
get into the server but
it's about to get a little hectic here
because it just they unlocked everything
ready to go yay
all right
looking for 22 more players
what's happening yes for those of you
joining in the battle of verdansk is
about to begin
excuse me it starts at 10 30. it is an
event inside of warzone
to promote the new call of duty vanguard
game so we're gonna have to do something
here we're gonna have to do an event
and then hopefully we'll get a teaser or
a trailer or something
to promote the new call of duty game
which comes out later this year
willie it should be live we're here
we're just kind of waiting uh you can
see at the top searching for a match
looks like we had a lobby of four people
a second ago but just farted on us
how do i start it you guys got to boot
up
your war zone your game of war zone and
make sure it's updated there's a quick
update
and hopefully hopefully this works
hey aaron look it's a good sign we got
all modern warfare style players there's
alex and there's uh uh what's his name
otter
look at that
look at us all these we're like wild
hogs we're like the old guys who are
like modern warfare forever bro
yes i think it's starting okay
come on please start
not this again
yeah it is a playlist update
come on game don't let me down it says
loading level this is good
let's go
oh yeah we got some
world war ii
non-fans in the chat that's okay i mean
we go back to world war ii so much
like it's a you know
like a fad in video games
man now we're searching for a match we
had a match going we had a match going
meanwhile luke in the chat says world
war ii shooters are the best
oh yeah man
okay um
huh maybe okay maybe now's the time i
can build a load out while we wait uh i
love there we go
em2 was okay it was jumpy but i have
really good luck with it so i might
i hate that i hate that uh optic i hate
that little square optic stick
that
speed mag no i need all 40 rounds you
guys know me already flinch resistance
i'm gonna stick with this
and a new stock option the duster pad
slide speed i'm good i'm good
okay well there's also the tec9 which i
unlock something for
oh another duster stock no thank you no
thank you
and
a goofy camo
okay come on
searching for a match come on come on
what time is the event dizzy the event
is supposed to start now it started well
it started at 10 30 but
since
10 30 we've been trying to get into a
match here
um
we got close the screen was like are you
ready and it's like loading the game and
then it just stopped so
last thing i want to do is like back out
because we got our place i thought got
our place in line here
searching for a match
morning brad see he says what up he says
good morning bud
werewolf in the chat says battlefield
will win all right i can live in our
world with both but
it's looking that being said it's
looking like a a battlefield a good year
for battlefield so i'm excited
goodness gracious this is
we were close
what happened to the reveal this is
what's happening we're trying to get
into
the battle of verdansk as you can see on
the left why am i pointing
um that's the event we're just trying to
get into it we're waiting
i hate hackers me too man
i'm so happy that playstation can uh you
don't have to play with um you don't
have to cross play if you don't want to
it's not like there aren't hackers on
console but
they get to me man they really bring the
game down today's been a great day for
that so far
we even won one look remember that
remember that you guys we even won a
match today
maybe because my skill bracket is so low
and they put me in bot lots just kidding
hey man i got like five kills on that
match
vietnam uh call of duty would be nice
yeah that is a
highly requested
idea
um and i'm all for it
like
i don't know why world war ii is uh very
much represented in video games and
media
let's do the vietnam war
you're a kid and you play these games
it's how you learn things too like
whether you're whether or not you know
it you're absorbing information you know
of course there's
a crazy story attached to it
you know they like to provide intel and
be somewhat faithful to history
i don't feel they're 999 playing call of
duty
guys i'm
i'm i am tempted to like
back out one time
and then come back in but i don't know
if that'll screw me up
we started restart the search it worked
for me all right
this happened last time i'm just
i've been staring at the screen for like
five minutes i'm just gonna try leave
with my party
then there we go battle over dance
wish me luck guys
the great war okay i restarted the
search thank you guys i appreciate it
see yeah
this is as far as i've got no i've
gotten way
here we go the match is about to begin
yes
i shouldn't say anything no wait hold on
loading level
check it out you guys i prepared a sound
for this
um
oh never mind we're really about to
start in three seconds
i'll save the sound effect i have a
sound effect yes yes here we
go all right you guys we did it
destroy the trade
hopefully you guys heard that i have a
sound board over here so we just have to
stop this train
uh i don't know how long the event is
for i imagine like you know an hour or
two
oh here we go back in for dance baby
we are the
dansky daddies nope not so i regret that
entirely we are the boys of her dance
where are my friends oh they're all over
the map okay we're just we're just
loading up here
are we no is this it oh yeah okay
waiting for lobby to flow one more
person
greetings from mexico all right hey
kill the train yeah
okay good it sounds like you guys heard
the sound effect
i have not been i have not played
i played a little uh war zone yesterday
uh and i am
it kind of feels good to be back not
gonna lie i've just been playing so much
zombies like i'm stuck on zombies
yes you guys 40 more seconds yeah
let's go
i don't have a 4k screen so i didn't do
the hd texture pack
and uh aaron oh my god aaron who i'm
playing with aaron sampson uh he did it
the other day
and it like erased his game he had to
like re-download the game
because their wording was so goofy i was
like hey do you want the h2 texture pack
and he's like yeah they're like cool and
they deleted the game
yeah we did it we're in
that's not aaron this is aaron
this person's beating me up
greetings from malaysia hi welcome
why are there green dots everywhere
that's a good question okay here we go
guys
spicy music
oh
there's aaron
there's me tying my shoe
paul b thanks for being here even though
you don't play warzone yeah one
parachute uh you do have a kind of an
unlimited parachute
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
oh i'm going straight for that bomb
all right aaron i'm jumping
so i'm not trying to get killed
hopefully everyone's just on board to do
the mission
i get killed by a bunch of trolls
that'll suck for the stream
we're friends here pve the enemy is the
train look at this
look everyone's jumping to the train
they know what to do
let's go
this is it
look at this squad squad goals to the
maximum oh my god
who died
how can you die oh you probably
shoot
i got a
[ __ ] argument i'm
no good at war zone i suggest otherwise
but
thanks
it is pve yeah here we go okay here we
go
oh my goodness
[Music]
train is approaching the ambush location
okay um
that's it let's go
we are here
what do we do fire like shoot everything
we got at it we're all freaking out
oh wait can we get in the car
anyone use this
oh there it is see the red targets there
we go
i hit something
100 points for me more
oh my god
this is the 10 car train going to san
francisco right now
oh my god
i feel like i'm contributing nothing
i need a car
let's go
aaron aaron at the wheel let's go
teamwork
oh my god
what him
this guy on the train
okay
oh no the train's moving i heard aaron
hunk the horn and i missed it
oh crap
let's go let's go let's go
i'm in the car if you want no all right
oh the car's about to blow up that's why
they had
we are just
oh you know what i just noticed at the
top
there is a little graph to show which
gun turrets are still
he is uh
uh aaron was my uh
i call walkers
how much time do we have i have not
looked around
this is awesome though
here we go
all right
oh
still there's love for battlefield i see
you guys
it's kind of a weird day to talk about
it
you
know
i won't hate on you
the exclusive rounds got me
it would be really cool and helpful but
i don't see them
in helicopters
oh i should have done it
all right
i want to see what it looks like
supplies
oh no no
it's on fire i can't stand okay good to
know
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
come on oh no
rats
all right
hey one of my teammates
oh
i think the best approach was getting in
there you go
this dude got on the car
oh
i watched the road i watched the road
going around going around real quick
there we go
now i have no friends
oh just back there dude we're finally
knocking out this truck
yo we are destroyed
how do you get it now
oh it's not moving anymore
yo
this is like
it's insane
it's like
the movies
just infinite ammo
okay i'm gonna switch to
game only mode just in case there's
something we need to see
get in your way
[Music]
oh
they're sending bombers get out of there
now
stay with me we'll come and get you
moving
right now
[Music]
the whole world is burning
sometimes
the only way to put out the flames
is with more fire
not
[Music]
for this
this is the theater at war rafter
there's no curtain call for bravery
bravery is what comes after
not what you wear in the moment
dropping bombs
[Music]
whatever we do
we do it together
pre-order now and get early access to
the open beta digital pre-orders get
instant access to the night raid
mastercraft and black ops cold war and
war zone
okay i'm back
sorry i'm muting myself to make sure you
guys got to see that
um
great if we we are about to wrap it up
here thank you guys for joining there's
probably a lot of questions
we got to watch
that trailer
and go to an event like a week ago
and if you want to know more about what
you just saw we have a great breakdown
that was published today
like about 10 minutes ago so check out
gamespot on youtube
and uh thank you guys for joining we
have quakecon coming up in a little bit
um
here for another live stream but that'll
do it for me thank you guys all for
watching
um
and and and uh
it was a great stream i appreciate you
guys being around make sure you drop a
like and if you want to see more live
streams and stuff like that make sure to
comment and subscribe and all that stuff
until then let me swap out over here
hey thank you guys for watching and i'll
see you guys